[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
it seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're disabled too
austere kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly well you
need your fake family to stand up for
you hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson
I choose you
Mussa champion
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir sure Sam wait for real
sigh okay Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah that's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing okay why are you sucking your
bum stars your phone charge
beeps like a bad guy right
I demand an evite
you have full immunity I will prove
you're dead sorry about your window but
now you're welcome for not getting
robbed oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]